yeah  that's ridiculous  knight e4  make make it funny but queen h4 it's  just so bad  queen c70 plays oh no  queen c7 well he was probably thinking  about d5 and then decided to just  let me just play for the same way  i think so  because you probably have to calculate  all that  and if you don't see it clearly  you just go for the safe obvious move  queen c7 yeah so guitar is going to play  it slow  he's preparing bishop e6 and b6  he  he was fighting with his urges to play  active he  he won  sometimes sometimes there's a fight  inside a player  d4 by the way is played so we have a  couple of moves suddenly  i think we might actually see an  increase  in uh in the in the speed  uh because queen c7 this has to be an  expectation for lavon and also d4 had to  be  what hikar was expecting for the one to  play  how do we make this exciting here